live local now good evening a shooting
in a north las vegas neighborhood leaves
a mother dead and her son in custody
thanks for joining us i'm denise valdez
and i'm brian loftis this happened near
camino el dorado parkway in clayton
that's pretty close to c strand park
madison kimbrough now join us live she
spoke to neighbors along with the father
who shares that his son suffers from
severe mental disabilities here's the
story
i just saw a whole bunch of police cars
and my mom told me that she heard
gunshots police say a 64-year-old woman
was shot and killed monday by her
31-year-old son who was now in custody
the man's father tells 8 news now that
the mother who does not live at the
house was visiting their son andre when
he pulled out a gun and shot his mom by
her car
the father who didn't want to be on
camera says andre has bipolar disorder
and schizophrenia and had been taking
his medication at the time neighbors
like fernanda jones have lived in the
neighborhood her entire life and says
this is a tragic scenario and not
typical this neighborhood is really calm
you can leave your doors open and
nothing will happen it's
like a calm neighborhood nothing happens
here the father says his son andre got
into a safe at the house where he keeps
his firearms and took his gun the mother
was transported to the hospital where
she later died currently no word on what
charges the son will now be facing in
north las vegas madison kimbrough live
local now